all right Ryan is it with us in Phoenix
hi Ryan how are you how are you good how
are you how can I help
good good um we had a quick question for
you in regards to both my wife possibly
quitting and how we're in baby step 2
what does she make question is what's
that what does she make your wife she
means twenty-nine thousand a year okay
what do you make I mean set B - okay all
right so we're 100k and how much debt do
you guys have not counting your home
about a hundred and thirty five good
lord what is that on a student loan debt
for the most part that's 115 two cars
which is about 20 and I understand like
that because we have about six thousand
in credit card debt okay so it's like
141 yeah about that yes okay
all right and two cars that are twenty
each or twenty total twenty total and
break those down for me between the two
cars uh so ten and ten pretty pretty
close pretty anything okay yeah but just
the big bulk of it is student loans
who's the doctor or the lawyer uh I'm
the CPA a CPA okay so you got a master's
in accounting okay yes I do all right
and and so she wants to quit the 29,000
and come home how many children do you
have in daycare we have one in daycare
and we were contemplating whether to
have another one sometime soon okay
all right and what is the trajectory on
your income do you think I mean you're
at 72 now where will you be in three
years
uh well next year I'll be up to 85
hopefully I mean that's the plan and
then in three years over a hundred okay
all right so
not a big hit on your budget over the
scope of your life for her to come home
sure especially we are spending about
12,000 on a carrier yeah and you're
spending money on her travel and her
clothing for work and her you're
probably spending some extra money on
food that you wouldn't spend if she were
at home cooking and so if she comes home
and becomes consignment sale queen and
coupon clipping queen and cook from
scratch which is better for you and a
lot cheaper Queen then she probably
y'all can probably come close to
breaking even with her coming home yeah
yeah and that's what I said here
like I said we're in baby step two right
now our goal this year is to pay about
thirty thousand in debt and the one
other thing that you want to need to ask
as if you were opposed to instead of
paying the smallest debt first paying
our highest payment first
I would so for example are we owe 250 a
month I would pay then I would pay the
smallest debt off first I'd work the
debt snowball the way we teach it it
works that way and it's not it's not a
payment issue if you want to get rid of
that payment sell a car but I'm here and
because that's what we're talking about
but uh you know it that that's or maybe
wait till X debt is paid and then she
comes home you know or something along
those lines but it's borderline now
here's the thing she really is going to
have to be a true home economist in
every stretch of the imagination for
this to work okay
for this to work on the short term on
the long term it works fine because your
income shoots up so fast and then you
guys have to live on nothing you have a
lot of debt right if a real mess right
you're right that we know now and so
it's going to be I mean you have three
years of beans and rice rice and beans
maybe four do yep that's about what I
figured it out yeah to get this to get
this mess cleaned up and so yeah but I
would I would come on home and if that's
her desire to do that and the other
thing she could do is consider doing
some work from home or starting a small
business from home that's kind of the
business boot
movement that has blown up with a lot of
ladies who are very capable but want to
spend time with their babies at home but
also around that are starting and
operating small businesses of all kinds
I mean anything from accounting services
to graphic arts to Etsy stores or eBay
stores to whatever I don't care is it
but it's not believe me it's a lot of
very professional things and a lot of
arts and crafts things and a lot of
writing and a lot of different ways are
marketing themselves and actually can
make sometimes more money doing that a
lot of times more money than they could
with a low paying job of some kind so
there's quite an entrepreneurial
explosion among moms going to be at home
business boutique comm for more info on
that this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than
same room to channel tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you